jacobo cobra 90 pesos la hora como
pintor la siguiente gráfica muestra el
número de horas que tardan en pintar los
diferentes cuartos de una casa cuanto
compra por pintar una sala jacobo y
bueno aquí tenemos una gráfica que es un
pictograma o una gráfica de dibujos y
ésta nos muestra cuánto tiempo tarda
jacobo en pintar algunos cuartos
distintos de la casa y una cosa que es
muy importante es esta pista que tengo
aquí aquí lo que nos dice es que cada
una de estas tuve estás representan tres
horas de su tiempo así que no hay que
olvidar esta información que nos dan
ahora bien nos preguntan cuánto cobra
por pintar una sala así que primero
vamos a aplicarnos en la gráfica en
donde dice sala y si observas es justo
por aquí y ahora vamos a fijarnos en
cuántas cubetas tiene pero recuerda que
cada una de estas cubetas equivalen a
tres
horas de su tiempo cada una de estas
vetas equivalen a tres horas de su
tiempo entonces aquí tenemos tres horas
más otras tres horas eso nos da un total
de seis horas para pintar una sala
entonces jacobo tarda seis horas en
pintar una sala pero ojo no nos
preguntan cuántas horas tarde en pintar
una sala lo que nos preguntan es cuánto
cobra por pintar una sala jacobo y bueno
observa que acá arriba nos dan la
información de cuánto cobra jacobo por
hora de su trabajo dice que 90 pesos por
hora como pintor así que hay que
multiplicar estas seis horas que se
tardarán en pintar una sala por 90 pesos
que cobran por cada una de esas horas
entonces tenemos 90 pesos por seis o
seis veces 90 pesos lo cual es lo mismo
que 540
déjame ponerlo 540 pesos
jacobo ganan un total de 540 pesos por
pintar una sala y ya está